as we mentioned breaking at the top of
the show outrage growing tonight over
excerpts from a new book by bob woodward
and robert costa of the washington post
acclaimed joint chiefs of staff chairman
mark milley promised china's top general
advance warning if donald trump as
president launched an attack during his
final days in office well now the
pentagon hasn't yet issued an
on-the-record statement some sources are
telling fox's own jennifer griffin that
millie never did explicitly promise
china a heads up so we're going to
follow this story obviously very closely
but millie is the highest ranking
uniformed officer in the u.s military
and two top washington post writers are
reporting that he undermined a duly
elected commander-in-chief promising to
provide one of our country's most
serious enemies with advance notice
should we need to attack them now
tonight many are wondering if this is
true is this treason will milly be
punished will he be tried
court-martialed uh anyway should he ever
be trusted again it was his take on all
of this we call him the great one for a
reason eight consecutive weeks number
one new york times best seller uh now
over a million copies sold it's called
american marxism
call them the great one mark levin also
life liberty levin mark i'll let you
take it from here on general milley
well we're experiencing american marxism
aren't we a couple of things here sean
number one woodward and costa are
reporters for the washington post
takes two and a half to three months to
print a book
that means woodward and costa and the
washington post if this is true sat on
this story for months and months
why would two reporters sit on a story
like this for months and months
and allow this man who i believe if this
is true is utterly unhinged to serve as
the head of the joint chiefs of staff
you have two so-called journalists who
sat on this for two or three months a
news story they're journalists i'm not
why would they do something like that
you know why sean this is what woodward
does they drop this before the sunday
before his books are released they get
everybody worked up and stirred up maybe
they should be maybe they shouldn't
he'll be on all the sunday shows so he
and costa two so-called reporters can
make millions of dollars off this book
and what does this book do it's
certainly in the front end it attempts
to trash president trump let's take a
look very briefly at this so people
should boycott this book people should
not reward these people at all for their
conduct as so-called journalists
journalism is corrupt and it's dead in
this country but let's look at the story
first of all it says
in the middle of the story peril the
author says based on interviews with
more than 200 people conducted on the
condition they not be named as sources
who the hell writes a book with 200
anonymous sources 200 well we have the
tapes we have the notes yeah but we
don't the american people this is our
country don't we get to make a judgment
about these things it's not about
woodward costa and the washington post
what kind of a news organization is this
and if this did happen it's big news
i've spent my life studying and
defending the constitution of the united
states you have here mark milley not
once but twice before the election and
after
contacts the head of the communist
military in china our number one enemy
and the first time he does it it's based
on he's concerned china's worried our
military exercises in the
uh south china sea uh deepened by
trump's belligerent rhetoric toward
china so he calls china around the back
of the commander chief
and tells them don't worry about him i
have him under control pretty much
what is what and then after the election
he calls and he says quote general lee
you and i have known each other for now
five years if we're going to attack i'm
going to call you ahead of time i'm not
going to be it's not going to be a
surprise if the united states military
just theoretically it's going to attack
china the head of the joint chiefs of
staff knows every step of it he's going
to tell the enemy
if that's true this sob needs to be out
of there as fast as possible without a
debate
what else does he do basically according
to this article if it's true he tells
his subordinate officers basically to
take an oath of loyalty to him
to him what else does he do he conspires
with the head of the cia who's worried
about a right-wing coup all this talk
about right-wing coups russia collusion
criminal investigations of a sitting
president two impeachments one of a
sitting president one of the the
ex-president when he's left office going
after tax returns trying to destroy we
know what a coup looks like we sat with
it for the last five years and what else
the head of the joint chiefs is
collaborating with the head of the
opposition party pelosi and schumer so
he's collaborated according to this
story with the communist chinese
military with the head of the democrats
in the house with the head of the
democrats in the senate he's got
subordinate generals and others who he
according to this story gets allegiances
from them
and the two reporters on the story sit
on this for months and months and months
so they can make a buck on a book
wouldn't it have been good to know about
millie before what happened in
afghanistan so his ass could have been
kicked out of office so we could get a a
general in there
like a george s patton type who wouldn't
leave american citizens in enemy
territory who wouldn't leave patriotic
afghans in enemy territory who are being
hunted down and killed as i speak with
85 billion dollars of our equipment
general milly probably the worst general
we've ever had
if this story is true and if the story
is false
my god general miller you're going to
own the washington post why don't you
come out and tell the american people
everything and america boycott these two
journalists boycott their book they
shouldn't make millions of dollars
sitting on a story if true that we the
people had a right to know that the
military had a right to know before
afghanistan a park on all their houses
and let's be clear
yes they were all of them after
president donald trump it's the most
disgusting thing i've seen in my life
from the intelligence agencies to the
defense department to the fbi to the
democrats to the media how sickening you
want to see a coup
there were your attempted coups i'm done
american marxism bookstores everywhere
amazon.com mark show life liberty levin
every sunday right here at fox 8 pm you
don't ever want to miss hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else